bonjour à tous je veux remercier de
nouvelle fois Éric ver
vraiment Isabelle toi aussi Isabelle KC
Gérard Cherpion vous tous qui êtes venus
les parlementaires qui ont
travaillé les amis de
l'extérieur et si vous me permettez de
donner mon point de vue dans ce débat
j'aimerais que tout ne soit qu'une
question de
simplification
avant la
simplification il y a l'affirmation des
valeurs la simplification c'est un moyen
au service de
valeur suffit pas de dire simplifiant il
suffit d'abord de dire à quoi nous
croyons simplifier sans dire avant à
quoi nous
croyons c'est comme un bateau sansquille
il y a une ligne il y a des
valeurs un pays porte des valeurs porte
des croyances porte un idéal et l'idéal
ça peut pas simplement être de
simplifier simplifier une mauvaise idée
c'est une mauvaise idée
simple donc si vous le permettez même si
je partage pleinement l'objectif de
simplification je veux d'abord prendre
quelques minutes pour dire à quoi nous
croyons je préfère toujours qu'on parte
des causes pour aller aux
conséquences encore une fois la
conséquence la simplification la cause
nous croyons à quoi nous croyons qu'il
n'y a pas de vie épanouie pas de vie
heureuse sans le travail que le travail
n'est pas une aliénation que le travail
est une émancipation que tout doit
partir du travail que l'homme et la
femme que l'être humain nous sommes
faits pour deux choses aimer et
travailler travailler et
aimer que c'est le cœur du message qui
est le
nôtre il y a pas de
contradiction simplement que dans
l'échelle des
valeurs que vont porter les républicains
il y a la question centrale du travail
il n'y a pas de vie épanouie sans
travail le malheur de la vie c'est celui
d'une personne qui est exclu du travail
et notre
objectif doit être que chacun de nos
compatriotes puisse avoir un travail pas
forcément d'ailleurs un travail marchand
parce que tout le monde n'est pas en sit
physique mentale économique d'exercer un
travail mais qu'il n'y a pas de vie
possible sans que celui qui vit ne se
voir reconnaître une utilité dans la
société et cette utilité passe par le
travail j'en tire si vous permettez une
deuxième
conclusion si vous êtes d'accord avec
moi sur cette direction là à quoi sert
le code du
travail la question n'est pas de faire
simplement un code du travail simple
bien
sûr la question c'est quel est
l'objectif du Code du
travail l'objectif du Code du travail
pour moi n'est pas simplement de
défendre ce qu' un travail mais de
faciliter l'entrée dans le travail de
tous ceux qui n'en ont pas le code du
travail est au service du travail pas
contre le
travail pardon
de pardon je sais c'est très simple ce
que je dis mais c'est l'avantage que moi
déjà je peux le comprendre et quand
l'orateur comprend ce qu'il dit il y a
une petite chance qui convainc quelques
personnes la vérité du Code du travail
aujourd'hui c'est que ce code du travail
défend ceux qui ont un travail mais
éloigne du travail les quelques 6
millions de nos compatriotes qui n'ont
pas de
travail je voudrais dire sans porter
atteinte à personne que le système
social aujourd'hui et notamment de
représentation syndicale est fait et est
là pour défendre les statuts de ceux qui
ont un emploi un salaire une
rémunération une occupation un travail
et ne s'occupe en rien de ceux qui sont
des chômeurs de ceux qui n'ont rien de
ceux qui voudrai se voir reconnu une
compétence en travaillant c'est ça que
nous voulons changer et nous disons le
problème du Code du travail bien sûr sa
complication mais le code du travail est
compliqué parce qu'on a oublié l'utilité
du Code du
travail il n'y a pas de simplification
sans qu'on fixe une ligne la ligne c'est
cela on veut mettre le code du travail
au service du retour à l'emploi de nos
compatriotes un dernier mot sur la
simplification je le dis au
parlementaires
attention que la simplification de la
norme législative ne soit pas remplacé
par la complexification de la norme
[Applaudissements]
jurisprudentielle c'est pour dire que
avec les meilleures volontés du monde
parfois les idées les plus simple
excusez-moi si le législateur fait un
code du travail divisé par 3 je le
souhaite mais que dans le même temps ce
même code du travail donne une
possibilité sans limite pour la
jurisprudence et pour la doctrine à
l'arrivée vous n'aurez rien gagné du
tout à partir de de de ces quelques
premières euh réflexions
où voulonsous aller et que voulons-nous
faire la première des choses pour
nous j'ai vu que monsieur Vals
m'appelait à dire la vérité oui je vais
lui appeler moi à lui dire quelque chose
avant de la dire il faut la voir la
[Applaudissements]
vérité la vérité cher
Christian c'est qu'en France depuis des
années et des années on adore dire qu'on
dialogue et plus on dit qu'on dialogue
moins on
dialogue la vérité c'est qu'il n'y a
aucune chance de changer quoi que cela
soit dans les habitudes les contraintes
et l'immobiliste de la démocratie
sociale chers amis on parle souvent
d'une démocratie politique qui
fonctionne mal c'est
vrai et nous avons bien des progrire
mais que dire de la démocratie
sociale il n'y a pas de dialogue
pourquoi parce qu'en vérité la parole
est donnée aux appareils et non pas au
salariés de l'entreprise et aux chefs
d'entreprise qu'il s'agisse de tous les
partenaires sociaux et pas simplement
les partenaires sociaux
salariés pour nous c'est clair la base
le lieu du dialogue c'est l'entreprise
bien avant la branche bien avant le
confédéral l'entreprise doit être le
lieu naturel de l'expression du dialogue
social naturellement il y a des
exceptions et je reconnais bien
volontiers que la branche cherérique
cher an
elle est
nécessaire lorsque l'ensemble des
adhérents de la branche sont constitués
de toutes petites entreprises je
reconnais bien volontiers que la
boulangerie que les cafés restaurants
que les petits commerçants la branche a
une légitimité mais il n'empêche nous
les républicains nous voulons affirmer
après les valeurs une première idée
forte centrale le lieu naturel normal
efficace du dialogue c'est
l'entreprise à partir de
là définissant la géographie du lieu du
dialogue est-ce qu'on peut s'arrêter un
moment sur les
interlocuteurs je veux dire une chose je
je sais que sans doute ça choquera mais
je la considère
comme
nécessaire les délégués syndicaux
doivent être élus et non plus
nommés quelle est la représentativité de
gens qui sont nommés par rapport à
d'autres qui sont
élus ce qui veut dire une proposition
que je auquel je tiens
beaucoup je souhaite que la démocratie
française accepte cette idée simple de
liberté de candidature dans l'entreprise
au premier tour des élections s'il n'y a
pas de liberté de candidature au premier
tour des
élections il y a pas de liberté dans le
dialogue qu'on est défi au lendemain de
la guerre des critères de
représentativité en fonction de ce que
fut l'attitude des uns ou des autres des
forces syndicales pendant la guerre je
peux parfaitement le comprendre mais je
rappelle que nous sommes en
2015 et je ne suis pas persuadé que la
France de 2015 ressemble absolument à la
France de
1945 il est peut-être le temps à
l'époque des réseaux à l'époque de
l'Internet dans une époque où chacun
veut donner son opinion de libérer la
parole et
l'expression tous ceux qui voudront se
présenter au premier tour d'une élection
pourront le faire il n'y a pas dans la
démocratie sociale française une forme
de
noblesse qui aurait plus de droit que
les autres de la même façon que dans la
démocratie politique imaginez ce qu'il
en seraiit si les partis que nous sommes
héritiers de formation politique
ancienne nous revendiquions le monopole
de candidature au premier
tour ça me fait plaisir de vous étonner
je vois qu'il y en a certains qui
avaient pas pensé à ça c'est
bien c'est exactement là qu'on ne
viennent pas me dire c'est exactement la
même chose nous sommes tous les
héritiers du gaulisme des chrétiens
déémocrates enfin je je veux dire des
des vieilles tendances très ancré dans
le paysage politique français nous n'en
tirons pas cher éic la conclusion que
c'est nous à l'exclusion de tous les
autres bon et le courant politique je me
rattache depuis que je suis rentré dans
la vie politique n'est pas moins
légitime que les grandes
confédérations syndicales que je
respecte par
ailleurs ça ne veut pas dire que les
syndicats de mon esprit n'ont pas une
une utilité ils ont une grande utilité
mais ne peuvent pas faire l'économie
d'un débat sur leur représentativité et
la
représentativité ça se détermine dans
les urnes ça ne se détermine pas parce
que il y
a des décennies on vous a reconnu une
représentativité à partir de ce
moment-là
continuons
l'entreprise liberté de
candidature suppression du préalable de
représentativité nécessité de défendre
sa
représentativité si les partenaires
sociaux dans l'entreprise quand il y en
a sont d'accord il a rien à dire s'ils
ne sont pas d'accord aujourd'hui on tire
la conclusion ils sont pas d'accord ils
sont pas d'accord mais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait bah on fait comme on a dit mais
comme on a rien dit B on fait
rien la proposition que je souhaiterais
que nous retenions c'est que dans ce cas
de
figure on sort de
l'immobilisme par le référendum interne
à
l'entreprise et qui osera me
dire qu'il n'est pas démocratique sur
des sujets aussi importants je vais y
revenir que la durée de temps de travail
l'organisation de l'entreprise la vie
dans
l'entreprise on passe pour ceux qui
travaillent parfois plus de temps au
travail que dans sa famille qui vient me
dire que ce n'est pas démocratique que
les salariés de l'entreprise puissent
exprimer par un
vote à la majorité simple parce que dans
la démocratie française excusez-moi
c'est 50 % plus une
ça nous a coûté François
Hollande je vois pas pourquoi on devrait
dire une majorité qualifiée 50 % plus
une voix pour trancher par
exemple la question de savoir combien
d'heures on doit travailler dans une
entreprise le référendum je souhaite
d'ailleurs que lorsque les salariés
d'une entreprise et les chefs
d'entreprise s'expriment par le biais du
référendum dans l'entreprise cette
décision pour peut naturellement qu'elle
respecte les normes fondamentales en
quelque sorte le droit social absolu
s'impose y compris au tribunaux qui
n'aurait pas à requalifier un accord qui
aurait fait qui aurait été le résultat
d'une consultation dans l'entreprise
naturellement il s'agit pas de
transformer une entreprise en lieu de
référendum on peut parfaitement dire
qu'on limite le nombre de référendum
dans l'année on peut même d'ailleurs
demander à ce que le une fois décidé on
lui fixe une limite dans le temps
d'application on peut en discuter mais
vous voyez ainsi dessiner sous vos yeux
un nouveau paysage social l'entreprise
comme lieu du
dialogue la représentativité de nos
forces syndicales refondé les salariés
enib en situation d'être les arbitres et
les décisionnaire
et la liberté laissée aux entreprises de
choisir leur temps de
travail parce que l'entreprise c'est un
monde mais il y a autant de différence
entre les entreprises qu'il y en a entre
nous naturellement il y a des points
communs entre
nous d'abord on sait pas pourquoi on est
né et on sait pas quand ça se termine
mais il y a des différences dans
l'entreprise c'est pareil je pense qu'il
faut renoncer à cette idée d'une durée
unique du travail dans l'entreprise
quelle que soit l'entreprise quel que
soit son carnet de commande quel que
soit son secteur quelle que soit son
exposition à la concurrence et nous en
venons donc à ce momentl à la question
des 35
he qui est une question sur laquelle
nous avons beaucoup travaillé et sur
laquelle on doit dire des choses fortes
pour que chaque Français soit en mesure
de comprendre où nous voulons les
conduire
dans ma longue vie politique je n'ai
jamais été de ceux qui ont
Bellé sur le progrès que représentait la
réduction du temps de travail
obligatoire et uniforme j'ai connu cette
époque à la fin des années 90 pour être
intelligent il fallait pour la réduction
du temps de
travail pensant que le travail devenait
agréable s'il était moins nombreux
la question n'était pas la qualité du
temps de travail mais la réduction du
temps de travail on était arrivé à 35h
mais madame voanet à l'époque réclamait
he d'ailleurs je me disais pourquoi 32
c'est encore
trop fort
heureusement cette époque est
terminée en
2007 avec les heures supplémentaires
déchargé et déc in janté nous avions
donné du pouvoir d'achat aux salariés 9
millions et demi qui en profitait et de
la souplesse aux
entreprises sans engager la France dans
les débats idéologiques qu'elle aime
tant se regardant dans la glace pour
savoir qui était le plus libéral le
moins libéral le plus dirigiste le moins
dirigiste les entreprises qu'elles
veulent c'est du pragmatisme donc voilà
comment nous voudrions
faire dans chaque
entreprise liberté serait laissée aux
partenaires sociaux ou aux salariés de
l'entreprise de décider s'il reste au 35
he ou s'il s'affranchissent les 35 he
c'est la liberté je ne voudrais pas que
l'on remplace une
loi de rigidité par une autre loi de
rigidité comprenez-moi la loi sur les 35
heur ou la loi sur les 39h c'est d'abord
de la rigidité or vous les chefs
d'entreprise vous avez d'abord besoin de
la liberté
laissons la liberté aux entreprises de
France de choisir de sortir des 35 he ou
si les salariés le souhaitent de rester
au 35 he je ne vois pas au nom de quoi
nous devrions remplacer une idéologie
par une autre une rigidité par une autre
une interdiction par une autre une
limite par une autre
liberté à ce
momentl les salariés de l'entreprise et
chef d'entreprise déciderai librement du
moment où commencent les heures
supplémentaires naturellement dans la
limite des règles de droit social absolu
la limite européenne les 48 heur cela va
de soi on me dit oui mais alors dans ce
cas-là que fais-tu des exonération de
charge pour les 35 he alors là il faut
voir la vérité en
face je ne vois pas ma propre famille
politique dire au nom du souci légitime
d'amélioration de la compétitivité des
entreprises on va vous supprimer 11
milliards ou 12 milliards d'exonération
de
charge je sais pas un esprit simple
comme le mien un peu de mal à concevoir
les
choses je pense que les exonérations de
charge elles sont acquises en revanche
je voudrais qu'on inverse complètement
le raisonnement madame
Aubri réduisz les charges pour que les
salariés travaillent moins je souhaite
que nous réduisions les charges pour que
les salariés travaillent d'avantage
voilà le changement complet de paradis
autrement dit mesdames et messieurs
messieurs chefs
d'entreprise plus on travaillera dans
l'entreprise plus on diminuera les
chargees ce qui permettra de créer du
travail de la croissance de la TVA des
recettes la folie c'est de baisser les
charges pour qu'on travaille moins alors
tout le monde sait que le pays a besoin
qu'on travaille davantage nous proposons
de baisser les charges pour qu'on
travaille
davantage je pose qu'une seule limite et
je veux être très clair entre entre vous
entre nous je n'accepterai
jamais un principe général au terme
duquel on dirait au salariés français du
public comme du privé travaille plus
pour gagner moins je peux parfaitement
l'accepter je fais écho à ce qui se
parte chez Smart ou ou ailleurs
lorsqu'il y a une difficulté lorsqu'il
faut serrer les coudes et lorsquil a un
mauvais moment à passer mais comme
politique générale je dis au français je
crois au travail je pense qu'on
travaille pas assez mais je
n'expliquerai jamais au français que
s'il y a une crise c'est parce qu'il y a
des gens qui gagn 1200 € par mois alors
qu'à la fin du mois ils sont obligés de
demander à leur patron une avance parce
queil y a plus rien pour faire brouir la
marmite ou faire vivre la famille ce
n'est pas la politique que je souhaite
que nous
défendions plus de pouvoir d'achat pour
les
un plus de liberté pour les autres
davantage de dialogue social voilà la
proposition
que nous faisons pour rassembler le
monde de
l'entreprise
j'ajoute bien évidemment on en a parlé
avec et
Isabelle la question de la sphère public
et du temps de travail dans la sphère
publque est clairement
posé
mais il est impossible dans le cadre de
cette demi-journée
d'épouser tous les sujets cher Gérard
parce que sinon à force de les épouser
tous on approfondit aucun mais
naturellement la chance de prendre la
parole à la fin de cette journée je veux
dire que la question de la durée du
temps de travail ne se pose pas dans
privé il se POS aussi dans le
public on y reviendra je souhaite qu'on
organise une journée de travail sur la
fonction publique mais qui me soit
permis d'en dire un mot
devantas
pris excellente dans son conseil
départemental je je considère
d'abord que ce fut une faute tous les
accords de réduction du temps de travail
des années
2000 que la vérité n'est pas dite aux
Français que nombre de services et
d'administration travaillent moins que
35 he dans la fonction
publique
28h 32h
c'est une réalité la nécessité de mettre
tout le monde dans la fonction publique
à 35 he est un
minimum à partir de ce
moment-là puisque la liberté sera rendue
aux entreprises de travailler plus que
he je souhaite que la liberté soit
rendue aux exécutifs territoriaux
communaux départementaux régionaux ou au
directeur d'administration
centrale de négocier une augmentation du
temps
travail dans leurs propres
administrations étant entendu que comme
il va falloir diminuer le nombre de
fonctionnaires et au minimum reprendre
le nonremplacement d'un sur de il va
bien falloir discuter tant de travail
puisqu'il y aura moins de
fonctionnairees j'ajoute à distination
des fonctionnaires qu'en disant
cela c'est un discours de considération
et de pouvoir d'achat car il va de soi
que s'il y a moins de fonctionnaires
s'il travaill davantage il faudra
remettre sur la table et dégelé le point
d'indice et j'accuse les socialistes
d'avoir trahi la fonction publique
d'avoir paupérisé la fonction publique
en refusant de toucher au nombre dans la
fonction publique ils ont pénalisé le
pouvoir d'achat dans la fonction
publique et le statut social dans la
fonction publique c'est cela la réalité
et c'est nous qui par l'EFF que nous
allons faire rendrons du pouvoir d'achat
de la considération et de l'espérance
dans la fonction
publique
tu tu tu vois Nathalie que j'ai des
soutiens féminins dans la
salle non mais c'est des sujets
extrêmement
complexes beaucoup plus sensibles qu'on
ne le
croit et je vous assure Nathalie
d'ailleurs pour emporter témoignage que
nous allons parler
longuement ça ne se traite pas par
slogan ça ne se traite pas par
ouaz ça ne traite pas uniquement par
symbole faut aller bien
au-delà je voudrais dire une autre chose
je n'emploie pas le mot
réforme mais le mot refondation je
voudrais m'en expliquer devant
vous il me semble impossible d'expliquer
aux Français que la situation est
tellement
grave queil y a un
risque pour la pérenité de notre modèle
social pour la pérenité de notre
économie pour la pérenité de notre
culture et venir simplement annoncer une
réforme technique c'est une véritable
refondation à tous ceux qui adorent
parler de notre modèle social il est
quoi notre modèle social aujourd'hui une
fabrique à chômeur à exclusion à
amertume et il est temps de le refonder
de le repenser pour faire quoi pour
faire que tout personne en âge de
travailler ayant la santé pour
travailler puisse
travailler ça qui va nous amener à toute
la question de l'assurance chômage et
des prestations
sociales sujet extraordinairement
sensible de mon point de
vue laallocation adulte
handicapé doit être
préservé et même é
à ce de nos
compatriotes qui ont des maladies qui ne
leur permettent pas d'affronter la
difficulté de la vie dont on ne parle
jamais sur lesquels on a pris beaucoup
de retard mais je veux dire que la
bipolarité la
dépression qu'on souvent on parle
maladie psychiatrique c'est assz
blessant à l'endroit enfin excusez-moi
j'ai rien contre la psychiatrie mais je
veux dire que il y a des des femmes et
des hommes qui n'arrivent pas à faire
face à la difficulté de la vie la vie
c'est dure et c'est pas leur faute et ça
doit être reconnu
comme je dis les choses comme comme
comme une maladie on ne demande pas à
quelqu'un qui vient de se casser la
jambe de partir faire de s'entraîner
pour faire le
marathon quelqu'un qui souffre comme
cela il peut pas prendre un emploi et je
pense que laallocation adul handicapé
non seulement vocation demeurer je
l'avais augmenté de 25 % comme vous le
savez mais sans doute cher amis à
réfléchir à une possibilité de l'élargir
à tout ce type de maladie dont on ne
parle pas hein pendant des années j'ai
entendu dire des gens qui étaient
dépressifs mais
secoue-toi comme si on pouvait bon et
bien malin ceux qui en parlent de
l'extérieur pensant que ça leur arrivera
jamais c'est qu'ils ont vraiment bien
peu d'expérience de la de la vie de
l'autre côté il y a le revenu minimum
vieillesse et le revenu minimum
vieillesse doit être naturellement
préservé puisqu'on parle d'une
population qui n'a pas vocation du fait
de son âge à travailler donc d'un côté
il y a ceux qui n'ont pas vocation à
travailler en tout cas à temps plein du
fait de leur santé de l'autre côté il y
a ceux qui NT pas vocation à travailler
du fait de l'urageche et bien au milieu
je crois qu'il est venu le temps que
nous réfléchissions à à une allocation
unique pourquoi une allocation unique
pour donner de la
lisibilité pour qu'on comprenne ce qu'il
en est cette allocation unique pourrait
rassembler le
RSA les aides personnelles au
logement et ce qu'on appelait la prime
pour l'emploi je sais plus comment on
l'appelle
maintenant la prime
d'activité ce qui permettrait voyez-vous
avec une allocation
que de lui donner une lisibilité
économique sociale et politique très
forte de la faire gérer par les même
administration d'assurer un contrôle et
de donner un sens est-ce que je me fais
comprendre comment voulez-vous donner un
sens politique à la prime pour
l'activité au RSA ou aux aides
personnels au logement j'ajoute que le
débat n'est pas épuisé il y a le
problème des aides locales un sujet
extrêmement important moi je souhaite
qu'on en tienne compte mais enfin c'est
un débat et à ce moment-là nous
pourrions indiquer très clairement que
toute personne qui refuse un emploi ou
qui refuse une une formation aurait
vocation à se voir supprimer cette
allocation
unique et que toute personne qui ne peut
pas chéri trouver un emploi ou une
formation aurait vocation à exercer une
activité au bénéfice de la des
collectivités ou de
l'entreprise activité rémunéré en
dessous du
SM ce qui permettrait par ailleurs de ne
pas rentrer dans un débat théologique
sur le SM mais tenir compte du fait
qu'un certain nombre des compatriotes n'
pas la formation ou les moyens d'entrer
dans un emploi March à ce
niveau voilà me semble-til qui donnerait
une une mesure
une incitation un nouvel ordre social
sur les indemnités de
chômage sais que je pas me faire des
amis ENF j'en ai
tellement je voudrais je voudrais je
voudrais
dire qu'il faut arrêter de manier des
concepts qui n'ont plus grande
signification et notamment le
paritarisme qui est bien souvent le
paravant de
l'immobilisme s'agissant du régime
chômage savez-vous que nous allons vers
un
déficit d'ici 2 3 ans cher Christian aux
alentours 35 milliards d'euros pourquoi
je cite ceci je veux pas vous accabler
de chiffre parce que cela représente
rien moins qu'une année entière de
cotisationement comment enz le régime a
un endettement à horizon de 2 3 ans qui
correspond à une année entiers de
cotisation reçu qui peut me dire que ça
peut continuer et bien dans ce cas-là je
demande que l'État prenne ses
responsabilités qui reprennent en direct
la gestion du régime qu'il prennent les
décisions pour que le régime soit
équilibré et qu'une fois équilibré il
rendent aux partenaires sociaux la
gestion d'un régime qui aura refait son
retard et réduit ses déficits cela
passera d'abord par le courage
d'affirmer la nécessité d'une
dégressivité des indemnités de chômage
on ne s'en sortira pas sans cela toutes
les études le
montrent la
dégressivité pousse à la reprise
d'emploi à la condition je pose deux
conditions d'abord je ne suis pas pour
une dégressivité très rapide parce que
quand le choc du chômage arrive ou de la
perte d'emploi je ne veux pas surtout
dans la situation économique
d'aujourd'hui qu'on met en accusation
des chômeurs alors que c'est tellement
difficile de s'en sortir parce que quand
on a 50 ans ou quand on n pas de
formation ou quand on parle pas de
langues étrangères ou lorsqu'on a mis un
genou à terre et qu'on a perdu sa
confiance c'est pas si facile que ça il
y a de la fraude je le sais mais on ne
peut pas dire que tous ceux qui ont pas
un emploi sont des fraudeurs parce que
c'est faux et donc je pense que la
dégressivité ne doit commencer qu'au
bout de 12 mois ce qui permettrait de
donner le temps à la personne confrontée
de pouvoir s'en sortir je souhaite par
ailleurs qu'on ne pénalise pas les gens
qui reprennent un emploi pour 3 mois ou
pour 4 mois bien au
contraire parce que même si ça dure pas
longtemps c'est d'abord un effort
fantastique de la part de ceux qui font
et je préfère de beaucoup quelqu'un qui
accepte de prendre un emploi de 3 mois
ou moi plutôt que c VI qu' refuse il
faut qu'on soit cohérent nous-même dans
les valeurs que nous défendons est-ce
que je me fais comprendre bon soit on
pousse les gens à reprendre un emploi
soit on on les sanctionne parce qu'ils n
reprennent pas mais si lorsque vous
prenez un emploi de 3 mois vous voyez
vos droits diminuer je vois vraiment pas
pourquoi on prévoit la
dégressivité mais chers amis restera un
dernier un dernier il y en a bien
d'autres encore mais un dernier problème
à mes yeux qui est celui des rapports
entre l'administration et notamment la
direction du travail
et les citoyens qu'il soit entrepreneurs
ou simples administrés je vais rappeler
une règle très simple c'est
l'administration qui doit être au
service des citoyens c'est pas les
citoyens qui sont au service de
l'administration dire cela ce n'estant
rien porté atteinte à la qualité très
grande d'une immense majorité de
fonctionnaires mais il y aun chose qui
ne peut plus durer cette a priori de la
culpabilité de toute personne contrôlée
est proprement
insupportable les citoyens les
entreprises ont vocation à être reconnu
comme honnête et respectant la loi sauf
à ce qu'on démontre leur culpabilité
c'est pas à eux de démontrer leur
innocence c'est à l'administration si la
quel chose àocher à démontrer la
culpabilité il conviendra
donc me semble-t-il de revoir le
déroulement des contrôles d'abord il
n'est pas interdit au ministre de
choisir un certain nombre de
priorité je pense que la santé au
travail en
étude je pense également que sur les
contrôles fiscaux qui sont bien
nécessaires pour lutter contre la fraude
ça doit pas devenir la règle qu'une
équipe de contrôleur s'installe chez
vous reprennent les comptes sur les
trois dernières années fassent perdre
des milliers d'heures de travail et
considèrent que la personne qui est en
face est un délinquant de grand chemin
avant même qu'au bout de 3 ans de
contrôle on se rend compte qu'au fond on
sé étranté et il n'a même pas le droit à
une lettre d'excuse l'administration est
là pour conseiller elle est là pour
soutenir elle est là pour expliquer elle
est là pour encadrer et elle est là pour
sanctionner le vrai eur pas le citoyen
de base ou l'administration de base je
veux le dire d'ailleurs parce que ça
m'amène à dire un mot du
licenciement l'idée que des chefs
d'entreprise sont
frénétiques à la pensée joyeuse d'avoir
à séparé de collaborateurs qui sont
parfois depuis des années dans
l'entreprise témoignent d'une
méconnaissance complète de ce qu'est la
mentalité d'un chef d'entreprise de ce
qu'est la vie dans l'entreprise et ce
que fait ce que doivent être les
rapports dans une équipe entre celui qui
dirige l'équipe et celui qui font
tourner l'équipe contrairement à la
pensée marxiste dont on penserit qu'avec
tout le désastre qu'a montré le
communisme partout a été dans le monde
on en a défini bien malheureusement dans
notre pays ça existe encore salarié et
chef d'entreprise ont un intérêt commun
et cet intérêt commun c'est la
prospérité de l'entreprise parce que si
l'entreprise n'est pas prospère les
premiers qui en souffriront ce sont les
salariés j'en tire donc la conclusion
qu'il faut passer d'une société de la
défiance à une société de la
confiance aujourd'hui on me dit ah mais
non mais le licenciement économique
comprenez pour raison économique est
possible c'est faux le licenciement pour
raisons économique n'est possible que
dans la mesure où l'entreprise et
subclaquante au bord du
précipice dans ce caslà on a le droit
donc ce qui amène à prendre les
décisions trop tard à l'arrivée ça fait
davantage de chôeurs et de DRAM si un
chef
d'entreprise estime qu'il doit séparer
de collaborateur pour des raisons qui
tiennent à la réorganisation de son
entreprise et pour des motifs
économiques par exemple il a perdu un
marché ça lui fait pas plaisir
j'estime que c'est au chef d'entreprise
de savoir ce qu'il a faire et ce qu'il
fait et que le contrôle du juge ne doit
pas être en l'urence un contrôle
d'opportunité mais un contrôle sur la
réalité comprzf d'entreprise March
est-ce que c'est vrai ou estce que c'est
pas vrai mais l'opportunité c'est chef
d'entreprise de savoir ce qu'il a à
faire et pourquoi il le
faitun chef d'entreprise qui aurait qui
serait séparé d'un de ses collaborateurs
d'un salarié de l'entreprise pour des
raisons
économiques soit obligé un an ou 2 ans
après s'il réembauche de proposer pour
les raisons strictement inverses j'ai
perdu un marché j'ai gagné un marché à
celui qui l'a licencié pour des raisons
économiques de revenir dans
l'entreprise le but étant vous le
comprenez que la France comme tant
d'autres économies modernes dans le
monde
Renou avec le plein
emploi bien sûr il y a bien d'autres
problèmes les seuils que vous avez
évoqué sur les seuils moi je crois que
ce qui est très important c'est qu'on
débarrasse les entreprises de moins de
50 salariés de tous
seuil possible parce que ces entreprises
là ont les mêmes ennuis que les grandes
sans avoir l'infrastructure pour gérer
le problème des
grandes sur le seuil à
50 la chose est un peu plus complexe que
je l'entends dire parfois parce qu' des
directives européennes qui imposent une
représentation ça compte moi je suis
engagé dans un combat européen et c'est
pas vrai qu'on peut RER ça d'un trait de
plume ce qu'on peut en revanche faire
c'est que les entreprises de 50 et plus
50 décident tranquillement ell-même
quelle doit être la représentation et
dans le même temps je souhaite
naturellement que soi supprimé les
commissions régionales pour les TPE créé
par ce gouvernement au mépris de la vie
des chefs d'entreprise vous voyez
qu'ainsi et je voudrais en
conclure on aurait réussi à tourner la
page de 3 AD et demi de politique
économique et sociale exactement à
l'inverse de ce qu'il convenait de faire
ça fait 3 ans et demi qu'on nous
explique que la croissance est de
retour ça fait 3 ans et demi qu'on nous
explique que ça va mieux il n'y a aucune
chance que ça aille mieux pourquoi parce
qu'on fait tout au niveau du
gouvernement pour que ça aille plus
mal notre
responsabilité sera de donner les moyens
à l'économie française aux entreprises
françaises de refonder l'ordre social et
la politique économique qui
NRE sans que dans le même temps notre
position soit si caricaturale qu'elle
éloigne de nous des gens qui seraient
tentés de faire la politique du pire
pensant qu'ils n'ont pas la place qui
est la leure dans le discours politique
qui est le
nôtre j'estime que le discours que je
viens de faire que la table ronde que
vient de présider ériic que le travail
qui est fait par gér et par Isabelle
s'adresse à tous les
Français salariés ou chef d'entre
Reise grand
entreprise compris commer et
Artis en
voyant sur le
R qui la
quessence de la fausse bonne idée qui se
termine en vra
catastrophe là aussi je suis pour la
liberté et bien qu'on donne la liberté
au
adhér de choisir entre régime général ou
le régime particulier on est pour la
liberté ou on ne l'est pas nous le
sommes et que par ailleurs cette façon
de faire où je voyais l'autre jour une
dame qui devait payer 75 % de son Bic au
RS et qui me dit comment je vais le
faire elle avait reçu une assignation
c'est-à-dire qu'avant même de discuter
on assigne c'est le contraire des
rapports que je souhaite voir naître
entre l'administration et les citoyens
voilà mes mes chers amis euh ce que je
voulais vous dire nous allons multiplier
les débats de cette nature vous allez
être amenés à exprimer votre opinion et
j'ai un message pour chacun d'entre vous
essayons de le faire avec
sérieux avec
ambition parce que la situation est si
grave que nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre petite choses avec le souci de
rassembler tout le monde autour de nous
ce qui ne veut pas dire faire des
compromis à l'eau tiède ce qui veut dire
exprimer franchement ce qu'il en est et
puis viendra la question est-ce que vous
allez le faire je veux dire terminer par
là parce
que la politique c'est au fond une
grande école
d'humilité les 5 années où j'étais
Président de la République mes propres
amis n'ont cessé de me dire mais tu vas
trop vite tu en fais trop
comment il disait
omniprésident parfois je vois les
mêmes doivent pas avoir la même mémoire
que
moi n pas vécu les mêmes choses qui
disent on aurait dû
on je suis fier de ce qu'on a
fait mais aujourd'hui je suis conscient
qu'il faut aller plus
loin pourquoi parce qu'entreetemp on aa
subi 5 années de gouvernement
socialiste parce que a rejoint parce que
aussi permettez-moi de vous dire Claude
le sait
bien la pensée s'est
libérée il est possible de dire des
choses et défendre des idées qu'on ne
pouvait pas le faire et parce qu'on peut
aller plus loin je veux qu'il pas
d'ambigué entre
nous j'aime la liberté j'adore le débat
je préside une formation politique avec
des
sensibilités multiples mais je
n'accepterai aucun
dérapage parce que je ne veux pas la
caricature de ce que nous
sommes estce que parfois j'ai
l'impression que certains dérapages sont
dit plus un souci de publicité
personnelle qu'à une réflexion
approfondie tout ce qui vient nourrir le
débat enrichir le
débat apporter un autre angle au débat
mais bienvenue il n'y a pas de pensée
unique ici je luttais toute ma vie
contre la nouvelle pensée contre la
pensée unique et je lutte aujourd'hui
contre la nouvelle pensée unique mais
que l'originalité de chacun dans la
famille soit mis au service d'un projet
collectif et non pas au service de
soi-même la légitimité de toutes ces
idées c'est la force qu'elles vont
donner au
collectif l'illégitimité de ces idé
c'est pas tant et pas simplement ce
qu'elles sont c'est le fait que ça fait
perdre en crédibilité au collectif la
victoire elle sera collective ou elle ne
sera pas et c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre tout le reste doit passer
derrière donc vous êtes dans une famille
politique où il n'y a aucun aucune
interdiction de débattre où toutes les
idées peuvent être confrontées mais où
chacun doit avoir conscience de ses
responsabilités spécialement à 2 mois
des régionales je dis à tous ceux qui
cherchent la provocation provoquez-vous
tout seul et laissez-nous conduire et
préparer l'alternance dont la France a
besoin